wir sind zurück bei esi german bei uns
ist heute der thomas thomas wo kommst du
her und warum bist du hier
ich komme aus den australian aber ich
vorne in tübingen süddeutschland aber es
ist mein erstes mal ich möchte ein video
mit ist schon sehr geil was fragst du
heute die leute ich frage die leute von
absinth sich süchtig sehr geile frage
wir sind gespannt auf deine antworten
hier ist ein mikrofon und los geht's
danach sind sie süchtig musizieren
gitarren spielen nach liebe vielleicht
und warum warum weil es mich so
glücklich machen von axt sind sich
süchtig nach reisen nachweisen und woher
hast du bist du gereist die schweiz über
silvester nördlich vom polarkreis und
hat noch nicht dagewesen und rentiere
und baden im fjord genau gummibärchen
gummibärchen und warum die beruhigen
mich sie machen wir gute laune
ich bin noch nirgends richtig schokolade
fühlen uns einfach ist und warum
schokolade press ihm ist gut schmeckt
man 18 sitze stieg
ich bin süchtig nach reisen
basketball danach sind süchtig
der musik tabak erwarten rauchen und wie
lange haben sie gebraucht
ich rauche immer noch auf meinem 21
lebensjahr von axe sind sie süchtig nach
wein waren ja lecker und haben sie ein
lieblingswein ihr grüner lecker und
würdest du ein vielleicht ein bisschen
heute abend winkel kommt darauf an ich
glaube oder einen trick ich chardonnay
und warum lieber als das beste ist was
es gibt und kennen sie ein leben ohne
liebe vorstellen
nein auch keine ahnung colada eiskratzer
und warum schokolade wahrscheinlich
angeboren
was ist er dein lieblings scharf gerade
seine lieblingsschokolade das ist die
zarte schokolade von edeka und nach sind
sie süchtig nach ist süchtig bin trend
wie lange haben sie erst seit er süchtig
und wie lange haben sie gebraucht seite
16 also elf jahre seitdem ich 16 bin
also drei jahre
okay die schokolade würde ich auch sagen
und welche schokolade also martin faber
marke habe ich nicht
und vielleicht haben sie einmal probiert
ein leben ohne zu rauchen oder wie hat
das geklappt
süchtig
das schwierig
bei gutem wetter auch unwetter gutes
wetter könnte man sagen
danach sind sie süchtig wonach nicht
süchtig nach sollte ich lieber sagen und
auch kaffee oder nicht ja kaffee und
zigaretten leider auch dass winter ist
auch okay kann man sich nicht abfinden
man weiß ja dass es kommt und dann passt
das schon zufrieden wenn wir das die
ganze familie und da kommen die her
kommen dass dem einigermaßen gut geht
von xsite erste stück nach was bin ich
süchtig nach kultur gerade gut tun was
für kultur hier berliner kultur gemälde
aber es gerade angeschaut war schön
also ich lese es gerade von imre kertesz
das leben eines schicksallosen dafür hat
er den nobelpreis bekommen und das ist
nur zu empfehlen weil es in einer ganz
besonderen sprache erzählt ist und aus
einer zeit die eigentlich noch alle was
angeht
riecht ein bisschen nach schokolade ein
bisschen nach bestimmten serien und was
serien es war verbotene liebe aber
wurde abgesetzt deswegen gerade gar
nichts danach sind sie süchtig nach
zigaretten
wie lange haben sie gebraucht immer noch
und solange geübt
kennen sie ein leben ohne zigaretten
vorstellen
ich bin dass ich hier irgendwo in
deutschland
das ganze problem was immer aufgebauscht
und immer größer wird und so das was wir
auch haben das cepr löst es uns schaffen
die leute hier alle willkommen und wir
das wohl irgendwie integrieren können
da bin ich sehr sich die nachhilfe auch
sehr
ja
du willst du bist und wie war's
es war unglaublich gold und hast du
viele interessante antworten bekommen ja
ein paar ein paar leute die eigentlich
nicht kenne ob sie ein wo du mich sicher
bist ob sie eine soziale aber haben sie
auch sag ich mal überraschende sachen
erzählt nicht schwierig liegt vielleicht
wieder leute haben eine suppe schokolade
und wahrscheinlich von den echten
sichten haben sie gar nicht erzählt ja
ich war dein gewissen thomas werden
sagen wie schön dass du dabei was wir an
euch aber in vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und diese woche ein spezieller gruß an
jay du bist einer von unseren zu
unterstützungspaket werden dafür möchten
wir heute von ganzem herzen danken
und ja sagen tschüss bis zum nächsten
mal wenn ihr uns auch unterstützen
möchte findet ihr hier unten den link
die experten unterstützen und hier unten
entwickelten chips bleiben und mehr
videos zu sehen
danke fürs mitmachen und wir sagen bis
zur nächsten woche
michael oenning fordert coach so jetzt
durch eine digital copy